Aufstand gegen Lauterbach
Ministerpräsidenten Ärzte Virologen
nicht alle aber immer mehr der
Bundesgesundheitsminister verweigert
sich ja der Realität ich weiß nicht
welche Studien er liest aber selbst eine
Reihe von anerkannten namhaften
Virologen bestätigen wir sind in einer
ganz anderen Phase ich glaube
tatsächlich dass die Situation
mittlerweile so ist dass wir eigentlich
unseren europäische Nachbarn Folgen
können und maskenpflicht oder Isolation
tatsächlich der Eigenverantwortung an
einem stellen können was ist da los
beenden wir jetzt die Pandemie ohne Karl
Lauterbach ich kann das nicht
akzeptieren oder hat er vielleicht Recht
und die anderen liegen falsch nehmen wir
doch mal gemeinsam seine
Argumentationslinie auseinander damit
ihr euch ein eigenes Bild machen könnt
natürlich hier bei uns seit Politik
ich bin Christiane hübscher
Korrespondentin im ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio
und berichte hier immer wieder auch über
Gesundheitspolitik naja und was da
gerade passiert das ist schon besonders
wie genervt bitte kann ein
Ministerpräsident sein wenn er den
Bundesgesundheitsminister so öffentlich
angeht und übergeht Schleswig-Holstein
ist Daniel Günther kündigt an genau wie
der bayerische Söder die
isolationspflicht aufzuheben und ärgert
sich laut und deutlich über Karl
Lauterbach wir haben viele Gespräche
auch geführt auf Bundesebene den
Bundesgesundheitsminister mehrfach darum
gebeten eine fachliche Bewertung
einzufordern aber daran schaltet es ja
schon der Bundesgesundheitsminister wie
vom RKI keine fachliche Einschätzung
haben sondern beharter drauf das
weiterhin die Regeln gelten er und
deswegen gehen wir als Bundesländer
jetzt eigene Wege und hoffen dass viele
andere diesen Beispiel
folgendes krass oder mindestens vier
Länder nämlich die drei unionsgeführten
Schleswig-Holstein Bayern und Hessen
aber auch das grüne Baden-Württemberg
diese vier machen jetzt genau das was
ihnen das geänderte
Infektionsschutzgesetz ermöglicht sie
entscheiden nämlich selbst welche
Maßnahmen sie noch brauchen und welche
nicht kippen also zu allererst mal die
isolationsregel und wie gesagt auch
Minister aus ampelparteien sind da dabei
wir haben in der Gesundheitsminister
einen Konferenz sehr sehr viele
gemeinsame Anläufe gehabt um den Bund
mehrfach gebeten diese Haltung zu
überdenken weil sie aus unserer Sicht
nicht mehr evidenzbasiert ist dazu gab
es aber keine Verständigung deshalb
glaube ich ist es jetzt richtig zu sagen
wir halten es nicht mehr für
verhältnismäßig Menschen zu zwingen sich
fünf Tage zu isolieren weil wir auch
keine über Drohne
überlassungsgesundheitssystems haben
keine 20 Minuten nach dieser Ankündigung
steht Karl Lauterbach im Bundestag
erkennbar wütend vor den Kameras das
kommt jetzt zu uns Halt und findet nicht
die Billigung der Bundesregierung aber
was heißt hier das kommt und Zeit gucken
wir mal kurz in die Statistik die
Inzidenzen gehen seit Anfang Oktober
zurück in allen Bundesländern und über
alle Altersgruppen die
hospitalisierungsrate geht zurück alles
ganz positiv eigentlich denkt ihr
vielleicht aber der
Bundesgesundheitsminister der sieht da
was ganz anderes nämlich ein ganz
düsteres Szenario am Vorabend einer
ansteckenden Variante und den Anbetracht
wahrscheinlich stark steigender
Fallzahlen mit schon jetzt 1.000 Toten
pro Woche ist es aus meiner Sicht nicht
wirklich verantwortbare Isolation sich
wegzunehmen fangen wir mal mit den
Todeszahlen an tausend Tote durch Corona
jede Woche sagt Karl Lauterbach dabei
ist das gar nicht belegt die genaue
Todesursache wird nämlich bis heute
nicht erfasst
gar nicht ob die Menschen mit Kurve
verstorben sind oder wegen Corvette
verstorben sind das ist eine sehr weit
offene Frage vieles deutet darauf hin
einzelne Fallbeispiele einzelne Berichte
die mir zu wird von den verschiedenen
Krankenhäusern dass die Mehrheit mit
kurbelt verstorben sind aber andere
Grundkrankheiten hauptursächlich waren
für das Versterben der Patientinnen und
Patienten und der virologisch mit
schanna sieht der hat mit dem
Todeszahlen Argument von Lauterbach
sowieso ganz grundsätzliche Probleme man
wird auch in den nächsten Wochen Monaten
Jahren Menschen haben die aufgrund einer
coronavirusinfektion versterben und
insofern wäre hier denn die Rückfrage
natürlich anhand Lauterbach welche
sozusagen was ist sein Ziel sozusagen
keinen Todesfall mehr zu haben der durch
sarskopf zweier hervorgerufen wird wenn
man letztendlich das als Ziel hat jede
Infektion oder ein Großteil der
Infektionen zu verhindern
dann ist man eben beim chinesischen Weg
wow der chinesische weg also das ist ein
ganz starker Vorwurf an laut der Bach
und den würde ich auch so nicht teilen
denn wir wissen alle in China werden
Millionen von Menschen weggesperrt
gleichzeitig wegen eines falls das ist
nichts was Karl Lauterbach will aber
unser Gesundheitsminister bleibt sich in
jedem Fall treu als ewiger Mahner und
Schwarzseher wir haben steigende
Fahrzeuge zu erwarten wir haben eine
ansteckendere Variante zu erwarten ich
möchte mal noch mal an die
killervariante erinnern die Herr
lauterbauer auch erfunden hat es ist nie
eingetreten auch bezüglich einer neuen
Variante die jetzt eben hier große
Probleme hervorrufen wird kann ich als
virologischer Sicht sagen da ist nichts
am Horizont zu sehen und die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür ist sehr gering
und das ist die Einschätzung sozusagen
der meisten Kolleginnen und Kollegen
gibt es auch Virologen Kollegen die
genau wie Lauterbach zumindest die
nächste Welle fürchten klar müsste man
die isolationspflicht irgendwann
abschaffen aber doch bitte nicht jetzt
so jetzigen Zeitpunkt halte ich es für
frühfrüht wir sind gerade durch die
herbstwelle durch die winterwelle steht
uns bevor die Erkältungssaison hat
begonnen also wenn wir tatsächlich einen
Interesse daran haben die
krankheitszahlen möglichst separat zu
halten dann sollte man da
isolationspflicht nicht rütteln na mal
sehen welche Bundesländer als nächste
rütteln schon jetzt sieht es jedenfalls
danach aus als gäbe es bald schon ein
Wiedersehen mit einem alten Bekannten
dem föderalen Flickenteppich überall
gelten andere Regeln und niemand sieht
mehr durch eine deutsche Erfindung da
schauen wir doch mal wie das im Ausland
läuft
[Musik]
in den USA ist die Pandemie von
Präsident beiden politisch beendet
worden und zwar schon Mitte September
die Pandemie ist vorbei sagt beiden also
klar habe immer noch zu tun mit corvit
aber die Pandemie sei vorbei in den USA
gibt es auch schon länger keine
isolationspflicht mehr es gilt das
Prinzip Eigenverantwortung der krank ist
bleibt zu Hause und das hat sich auch in
vielen unserer Nachbarländer inzwischen
durchgesetzt
schauen und wir haben keine
isolationsfläche mehr in Großbritannien
Portugal Spanien Dänemark Österreich
Schweiz Frankreich Schweden um mal nur
die zu nennen und die Bedingungen in
diesen Ländern sein vergleichbar mit
unseren sagt der Präsident der
Bundesärztekammer noch einer also der
ist anders sieht als Lauterbach der das
Ende der isolationspflicht für
verantwortbar hält das heißt keine
bagatisierung der Situation das heißt
auch nicht Entwarnung ähnlich sind also
das heißt im Lernen Selbstständigkeit
und vernünftig damit umzugehen und das
heißt natürlich auch sich zu isolieren
wenn man ansteckt oder erkrankt ist
Lauterbach aber sieht große Gefahren
wenn jeder der positiv getestet ist
nicht mehr klarverordnung zu Hause
bleiben müsste wir müssen auch bedenken
dass viele Menschen im Arbeitsprozess
wenn sie sich infizieren
long-zahlen begrenzen und die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
schützen und nicht gefährdet
genau und das wird dann gleich die
nächste Frage über die Streit gibt die
maskenpflicht im Verkehr noch gilt sie
zwar nicht mehr im Flieger wohl aber in
Fernzügen und dem ÖPNV kontrolliert wird
sie naja da habt ihr ja sicher alle eure
eigenen Erfahrungen gemacht und wieder
ist es der Ministerpräsident von
Schleswig-Holstein der als einer der
ersten vorprecht und laut über das
Masken aus im Nahverkehr nachdenkt unser
Ziel ist ja auch mit anderen
Bundesländern auch zu verabreden dass
wir hier zum Ende des Jahres auch
aussteigen es ist niemand gezwungen auf
eine Maske zu verzichten das heißt man
kann ja ÖPNV oder in größeren Menschen
ab Ansammlung wenn man sich selbst
schützen möchte auch eine Maske tragen
aber für staatliche Anordnung für
staatliche Maßnahmen er ist in dieser
Phase der Pandemie gibt es keine
Begründung die meisten anderen
Bundesländer wollen der aber erstmal
nicht mitmachen sondern an der Maske im
Verkehr festhalten genau wie Karl
Lauterbach nur Markus Söder spielt auch
schon offiziell mit dem Gedanken in
Bayern könnte im Dezember spät bis
Januar aus der obligatorischen
maskenpflicht eine freiwillige
Empfehlung werden wir schauen uns alles
genau an wir finden es zumindest mal ein
gutes Signal wenn beim Fernverkehr also
beim beim Zugreisen die gleiche Regel
gilt wie beim bei Flugzeug also weil so
richtig verständlich ist nicht wenn man
von Berlin nach München fliegt dass man
eine keine Maske verwenden muss wenn man
aber mit dem Zug fährt dass man eine
verwenden muss der
Bundesverkehrsminister sieht das genauso
kein Wunder er kommt von der FDP konnte
sie aber bisher gegen den
spd-gesundheitsminister damit nicht
durchsetzen jetzt aber nimmt Volker wir
singen einen neuen Anlauf ich hatte mich
schon bei der Abschaffung der
maskenpflichtigen Flugverkehr dafür
eingesetzt dass sie auch im Fernverkehr
der Bahn fällt ich halte es für
schwervermittelbar dass wir die
maskenpflicht im ÖPNV aufheben und sie
im Fernverkehr der Bahn aufrecht
erhalten wir haben nach der Abschaffung
der maskenpflicht in dem Flugverkehr
keine negativen Erfahrungen gemacht
unterstützung kommt hier auch von vielen
Vertretern der Ärzteschaft ich glaube
bei den Masken ist tatsächlich gekommen
wo man den
Menschen selbst überlassen kann ob sie
in gewissen Situationen für sich
persönlich lieber eine Maske tragen was
völlig in Ordnung ist und sicherlich
auch für manche Patientengruppen
empfehlenswert ist beispielsweise sehr
erkranke Menschen oder immunsupprimierte
oder eben auch nicht geimpfte aber das
kann glaube ich jeder Erwachsene nach
drei Jahren Corona mittlerweile selbst
einschätzen und Karl Lauterbach ist
natürlich gegen das Ende der
maskenpflicht in Bus und Bahn
[Musik]
ihr seht da entsteht gerade ein echtes
Problem für Karl Lauterbach wenn sich
dem Bundesgesundheitsminister
Ärzteverbände und Ministerpräsidenten in
den Weg stellen und sagen wir gehen
diesen Weg der großen vorsicht mit dir
nicht weiter dann wird es schwierig und
so wirkt Lauterbach auch sauer aber
machtlos wir können das leider nicht
verhindern weil wir nur empfehlen den
Charakter haben bisher ist es halt so
gewesen dass die Länder zusammenstanden
das ist auch ein Grund weshalb wir
erfolgreich waren die Länder standen
zusammen und haben diese Regeln
gemeinsam umgesetzt jetzt ist offenbar
diese Bereitschaft nicht mehr da ich
kann das nicht akzeptieren wisst ihr
noch Scholz hat Lauterbach zum Minister
gemacht gerade weil er als absoluter
corona-expertiger als auch weil er bei
Social Media so eine riesige Fanbase
hatte wo in so viele für seine Expertise
schätzten jetzt nach fast einem Jahr im
Amt hört man immer öfter der hat sich
Verfahren festgefahren in der Pandemie
der findet dann nicht mehr raus das ist
ja sehr offenkundig dass er sich sehr
schwer tut auch mit Regeln zurück gehen
man hat eben beim Gesundheitsminister
sehr sehr oft den Eindruck dass hier
eben nur bestimmte Punkte
herausgegriffen werden punktuell die
dann eben zu einer politischen Agenda
passen so und jetzt ihr haben wir
wirklich bald Lauterbach allein zu Haus
ist er wirklich der ein themenminister
der den Ausgang aus der Pandemie nicht
findet oder mögt Ihr vielleicht genau
das an ihm dass er seiner Linie so
unglaublich treu bleibt schreibt uns in
die Kommentare abonniert uns liked uns
und vor allem schaut all unsere Videos